In 1936 when Alan Turing wrote his
famous paper on computable numbers
he not only created
the Turing machine but
had a number of other major insights
on the nature of computation.
Turing realized that
the computer program itself
could also be considered
as part of the input.
There really is no difference
between a program and data.
We all take that as a given today.
We create computer code in a file
that gets stored in the computer and
no differently than any
other type of file.
And data files often have computer
instructions embedded in them.
Even modern computer fonts are basically
small programs that generate readable
characters at arbitrary sizes.
Once Turing took the view
of program code as data
he had the beautiful idea that a Turing
machine could simulate that code.
There is some fixed Turing machine,
a universal Turing machine,
that can simulate the code
of any other Turing machine.
Again this is an idea that we take for
granted today as we have interpreters
and compilers that can run the code
of any programming language.
But back in Turing's day,
this idea of a universal machine
was a major breakthrough.
It allowed Turing, and will allow us to
develop problems that Turing machines,
or any other computer cannot solve.